you're gonna look a bit
kudamon Burhan be the Somali Kenyan
version at Steven Spielberg maybe but
the difference is that demands films are
not purely commercial the man has a
mission and it's called East Lee would
you get here if which is someone who is
actually Freddy from Somalia from fled
from al-shabaab who's the refugee but
they are trying actually to they're
doing business like hawkeye's choose
China small small facility nobody is
sanitary service people are busy telling
a pseudo criminalist Ganges like and so
on so we are trying one way to tell our
culture our positive side among thousand
East Leawood in 2001 fourteen years
after he came to Kenya for young Somalis
his creative platform is the only way
out of ethnic isolation before I reach
my home I get exists for many people hey
man I would like to be active I would
like to be model of luck to be think I
would have to be that dance I am I
helping me out so immediately I should
sell I'll help you out as long as you
are talented sometimes I feel you are
passionate for this I'll make sure I
help you it's just right to mentor them
you know to motivate them and motivation
is urgently needed in the Somali
community after the terror attacks by
al-shabaab on arrow B's Westgate Mall
Iman and his colleague a Dan Osborne
have seen discrimination on every level
after I was to get the rims commercial
is pretty bad people they don't think of
us as good people they just condemned us
you know it's not you know when we are
like in a Matata and people start
looking at you like you know like a
suspect we don't deserve that al-shabaab
they don't stand for Somali eastling or
little Mogadishu is dominated by Somali
businesses a quarter of Nairobi's tax
revenue is generated here making it
vital for Kenya's capital and yet
Somalis are culturally isolated
some say a man's project offers ethnic
groups a chance to interact miss allude
is playing a big role a very big role
because it has reduced crime in a way
because most of the guys who are
perpetrating heinous activities in the
community most most of them have joined
and also showcase their talent isla
woods films are shown in tiny cinema
halls in the neighborhood the challenge
however is that Iman and his team not
only face discrimination from Kenyans
they also struggle with accusations from
their own community so many people
actually trying to disseminate a lot of
propagandas telling us you guys you're
changing our used you are getting
beautiful garnish yeah burr Mouton twist
and you know fairly news you want to ask
yourself what do I do with but I'm
saying today if I die there are someone
like Iman who will take from it and we
hope this Leawood who will work
generation is like Hollywood Iman's
project is funded by local businesses
and it turns out to be a very successful
one